MARCHANT TRIES TO
IT IN.
NO SIGNAL.
IT IS LOOSE NOW.
BOBROVSKY DIES ON IT.
THE CHART THOUGHT THEY PUT IT R
HE NEVER SIGNALED GOAL. ON THE
-- BACK IN THE LINEUP TONIGHT
FOR THE PANTHERS.
-- UP THE EYES.
IS
OFF-SEASON.
BACK IN THE STUDIO WITH
BARKOV AND BOBROVSKY.
YOU WANT TO SHOW YOU RE ABLE TO
IT OUT TO THEM.
TO THE LOW SLOT.
WATCH THE TRUCK.
THIS IS BEHIND THE NET.
LITTLEELUSIVE STANLEY CUP
CHAMPIONSHIP.
HUBER NO BACKHAND, SCORE. Kevin
YOU PLAY OF HIGH IN LIEU OF --
POINTS PER NET T
>> Kevin: YOU HAVE TO THINK
THAT   ON THE RED
WINGS HERE IN THE SECOND.
ONE
KNOWN MORE FOR HIS
NSEY WEEGAR.
LOOK AT THE ROTATION ON THE
PUCK.
>> Roxy: TYLER BERTUZUZIT FAR D
SHORT SIDE.
THAT IS A BIG TIME GO BY TYLER
RESPONSIBILITIES.
>> A 10.
MINUTE GETTING LOW.
A DANGEROUS TURNOVER -- IN FROM
FRONT OF THE
SCORE. --
NEDELJKOVIC. RIGHT HEART.
TO PANTHERS.
SECONDAND IT OVER TO STAN
REINHARDT IN THE MIDDLE.
REINHA YOU THINK ABOUT THE
TANDEM A BOBROVSKY AND TIGHT.
BARKOV.
SABINE A NEDELJKOVI